Ted GUP what is in your book the book of
honor the book of honor is about the men
and women who died in service to the CIA
who were covert operatives overseas and
in most of the cases their identities
were concealed were veiled in secrecy in
some instances for 10 20 30 even 50
years so the book basically reveals the
identities of covert operatives killed
in service to country and also the
aftermath of those deaths the burdens
borne by the families and the secrecy
they were forced to carry where did you
get the idea about during the Gulf War
about ten years ago I was at the agency
doing a history of us Iraq relations for
Time magazine and I passed before what
is called the wall of honor a marble
wall with black leather chrome stars
engraved each one representing a fallen
covert operative and in a bulletproof
glass case is what is called the book of
honor at the agency listing the years
each officer fell and in more than half
the cases just anonymous stars to
conceal their identity I saw that
memorial service and at that memorial
and it basically it touched me very
deeply and I decided then and there that
I wanted to know the identities of those
individuals on the cover of your book
what is this right here that is the book
of honor in the glass case it's it's a
locked case with very thick bulletproof
glass and stainless steel on the back of
your book and I may have quoted I mean I
may have counted wrong you have all
these names and I counted about 64 names
and and for women out of that group how
many names are there actually on the
wall
today including those that have been
acted since my book was finished 77
there 77 fallen covert operatives but of
those actually named it's about half why
only four women I think part of that
reflects the history of the agency in
which there were not so many women on
the front lines I think it's just a but
but in in in more recent times there are
a great number of women out there at
risk do you pronounce it Douglass
McKiernan
McKiernan exactly right you have a whole
page here the first group of photographs
of Douglas mckernon who was he
Douglas McKiernan was a much decorated
World War 2 veteran who early on at the
very founding of the agency in 47 and
about that at that same period
volunteered for one of the most remote
assignments in the world a room she in
cynjohn china Far West China and his his
mission was in large measure to monitor
the the Communists as they surged power
and to do it he could to prevent them or
at least Harris them and the reason he's
in the book aside from the fact that he
died in service is that he underwent a
1200 mile trek across desert and
mountains the Himalayas trying to flee
the Communists he got within about 50
yards of safety the tibetan border but a
message from the US government to the
dalai lama granting mckernon safe
passage was not delivered in time and he
was shot to death and beheaded within a
few steps of safety what's his
photograph right here of the with the
headline missing aides wife hits Reds
that is a picture of mckernon Swit Oh
Peggy and Mary and Mike the two one year
old twins he left behind it his death
the Chinese Communists accused him of
being a spy and indeed the Chinese knew
he was a spy the only people who did not
know he was a spy were the Americans and
it played into the demonization of the
Chinese and the Chinese government at
the time did the Americans know now that
he was a spy with publication of this
book but there's been nothing before a
piece I wrote in The Washington Post
Sunday magazine in 97 was the first
confirmation that he was a spy why are
you interested in doing this uh uh
excellent question
why am i interested in doing this I'm
I'm interested because I'm haunted by
the idea that we don't believe in the
past that it's not real for us that it
seems to be fiction and I'm haunted by
the Oblivion to which people who gave
their lives for country
are subjected or lost and by the fate of
the families the the surviving family
members who have been forced by the full
weight of the US government not to speak
of their loved ones for many decades and
indeed required to tell lies all those
decades to stick to the cover story at
the time of their loved ones death
I found that haunting and part of the
reason I wrote this and no small measure
was to try to lift some of that burden
it bothered me and the more time I spent
with the family members the more
bothered me how many people have you
talked to well I interviewed more than
400 covert operatives past and present
as well as several hundred family
members and you know I would say it's
eight nine hundred people all together
over the course of four years is there
one of those in that whole group one of
the families one of the the now-deceased
people that sticks out in your mind is
the best example of I don't know what of
what you found well I think there are
two but one that comes to mind is
perhaps the least glamorous of the
people in the book a Barbara Robbins who
was a 21 year old secretary in Saigon in
1965 she worked for the CIA
she was under State Department cover and
one day she heard some noise in the
street she went to the window at the US
Embassy in Saigon to see what was
happening and at that very moment a car
bomb by terrorists detonated and the
grating around the window impaled her
she was killed instantly
I cite her because she came from a very
patriotic family her father was a
butcher outside of of Denver Colorado
and when I spoke to him first in 1996
and 97 and again in 98 he told me that
that one of his final wishes in his life
was to see his daughter's name inscribed
in the book of honor not just an
anonymous star he wanted her recognized
he died last year with that wish
unfulfilled his his widow is still alive
and and shares that wish I cite her
because it's an egregious example
of the CIA's obsession with secrecy why
a 21 year old secretary who was killed
35 years ago cannot be identified after
all this time is beyond my grasp what's
this picture of a girls day Scout univer
that's Barbara Robbins when she was a
young girl and the picture above is is
also a picture of Barbara Robbins is
about the time that that she went over
to Saigon what happens when you asked
the CIA why they can't put her name on
that star anyone is welcome to ask but
they're neither confirm nor deny that
Barbara Robbins was a part of the agency
it's the standard line that they've been
issuing to these families decade after
decade and they told me no more than
they told anyone else in the public but
off the record do they tell you why they
won't no well I mean that there's a
generic argument the generic argument is
that they need to protect sources and
methods sources primarily means the
individuals who supply them information
methods are the ways in which they get
that information that intelligence
they're afraid they say that identifying
these individuals will put foreign
nationals and our own people at risk or
will compromise the way that we gather
intelligence back to Barbara Robbins she
was a secretary in Vietnam in Saigon
right how could that possibly have any
after all these years the the truth of
the matter is and I I'm not I'm not
someone that's made living demonizing
the agency but the truth of the matter
is that this is not an issue of national
security
it's an issue of bureaucracy there is
simply no constituency pushing for the
change the lifting of the veil of
secrecy a butcher outside of Denver does
not have enough power to lift the veil
of secrecy even on his own daughter's
name and that's why it's remained this
way year after year after year it is the
inertia of the bureaucracy and unless
and until someone plants a significant
political powder-keg under them they're
not going to change this is the way it
is it's always easier to ignore than to
change by the way where do you live now
we moved a year ago to Cleveland Ohio
for 21 years I lived in Washington why
do you live in Klee I took a position
endowed chair in journalism at Case
Western Reserve University and why did
you live here for 21 years I worked as
an investigative reporter with the
Washington Post under Bob Woodward for I
guess about eight years and then I
worked at Time magazine covering
Congress as an investigative reporter
that I freelanced from here for a wide
range of magazines for 18 years I also
taught as an adjunct at Georgetown
University and where's your home
originally Canton Ohio so it's a sort of
going home you mentioned there were a
couple Barbara Robins was one was
another one that did well not remember I
can't I can't help but but reflect on
Douglas McKiernan when I called his
widow Peggy I was the first one to put
together the fact that her husband her
late husband was CIA in 47 years and you
can imagine the shock when he died he
left behind twins who were one-year-old
and and to get a call out of the blue
saying I'm putting together the pieces
of a puzzle 47 years old she was
thunderstruck because for 47 years the
agency had told her you are not to talk
about your late husband and if you do
you must say that he was an employee of
the State Department a vice counsel in
the State Department
so she was she was just shocked when I
called her and I think it's an example
again the Chinese Communist knew he was
a spy
and his evidence of that they executed
everyone that he had contact with within
a year of mckennon's flight it was no
secret to the Chinese Communist it was a
secret to the US and what happens is the
u.s. paints itself in the corner they
say he was not a spy and then they lose
credibility when they admit that he was
it also plays into the the propaganda of
the Cold War that an innocent man was
you know on the run and slain how many
individuals do you write about in your
book well I focus on about 20 but I
named about I think about 35 who are
nameless how many of how much of this
information is brand-new I would say at
least 75 80 percent of it I mean this
was not gathered under the Freedom of
Information Act that was of no help this
was all kind of the old roll up your
sleeve hardcore sleuthing
was the only way to get it our people
and this book afraid that the CIA will
find out where you got this information
no it's it's it's a curious thing but
there's nothing off-the-record in this
book as sensitive and classified as it
is all the two families cooperated fully
in in writing this book some four
hundred covert operatives past and
present help me with this book when
someone is quoted by name there and it
says such-and-such said it that's
because they said it to me I mean
there's there's no there's no footnotes
but the sources are obvious in this book
it's it's it is exactly what it appears
to be and I think that the reason that I
got so much cooperation is that even
those who have dedicated their lives to
national security recognized that a lot
of this is preposterous that it still be
veiled in secrecy when did the CIA start
1947 why it was a sort of recollection
of the elements of the old Office of
Strategic Services in the world war two
entity following World War two it was
quickly disbanded and the elements went
to various places the State Department
the Defense Department and there was
quickly with the rise of the Cold War
perceived to be a need for some
centralized intelligence gatherer hence
the CIA and that was put together in
1947 largely bringing back together the
the disbanded elements of the OSS and
modeled no small part on that structure
the last one in your book is the last
maccabee why that title that's a
reference to the chapter is about Larry
Friedman Larry Friedman was Jewish and
very proud of the tradition the biblical
tradition of Jewish warriors going back
to the Maccabees he was a green beret in
Vietnam he was in the elite Delta Force
counter-terrorist unit that that made
the aborted effort to rescue the
hostages and Te'o ran and and he was
killed in Somalia he was the first
casualty in Somalia and I chose the the
title the last maccabee because I guess
that's I think what what Larry Friedman
would have wanted that
after to be you have a picture in here
of some of his friends where did you
find that picture and who are they that
picture was taken during an interview
that I conducted of the the four friends
Paul Weinberg on the the your viewers
left I believe with the white beard has
since passed away and indeed the book
was slipped under his hand as he was in
a coma as a accident the one on the
right don't you with my very sorry yes
I'm sorry the one he's passed away he
has since passed away we got a copy to
him a few days before publication
because he had wanted that but the
picture was taken by Larry Friedman's
sister Sylvia donor and these four
friends were incredibly loyal to Larry
Friedman and they gathered basically to
share stories about him with me
tell us more about him uh well he was a
Hellion I mean he was it was a kid who
before he reached thirteen held up a gas
station with a bow and arrow I mean a
real hunters bow and arrow he sawed off
the top of a car to make it a
convertible
he drove Harley's at high speeds he got
more than a little trouble and were not
for his finding the green berets and the
military I'm not sure exactly what would
have become of him but it was a perfect
match and it harnessed all of his
excessive energy and his incredible
courage and his patriotism and it was a
perfect match and and he became one of
those who trained Delta Force at Fort
Bragg and was brought into the CIA
upon retirement from Delta Force and he
became one of their he was renowned as a
sniper he could he could run five six
seven miles with a full pack set up his
rifle and and wait for two or three days
for ten seconds of a window when someone
passed by - to do what he did as a
sniper I mean he was a it was deadly
accurate deadly patient and a perfect
physical specimen and very patriotic
what happened to him in Somalia all of
those resources and skills that he had
were of no avail the vehicle he was in
hit a landmine a Russian
landmine and he was immediately killed
he would he was near bardera
and he was there to ensure that airports
were open so that food and relief
supplies could reach the starving people
of the country he was not there
in the capacity as a sniper he was there
as a kind of intelligence officer and
liaison between the incoming US military
and the embassy and and other elements
of our US and what year did he get
killed 92
December 92 is his name up on the wall
out there at the CIA Accord oh he's an
anonymous star how many names again are
on the wall this is a rough guess about
half of the 77 are named maybe as many
as 40 the rest are nameless can I go out
to the CIA and see this wall you as a
journalist can but the ordinary citizen
cannot you need a reason an invitation
to to get in to the the the headquarters
at Langley how did they deal with you
and I know you were doing this book the
first person that I interviewed was the
chief of public affairs of the CIA this
was not done in any kind of Subrosa
fashion because I knew I'd be setting
off trip wires and alarms left and right
I mean I knew I was going to have to
interview hundreds of covert officers
and that probably the first time I made
a call it would get back to CIA
headquarters so I called their public
affairs staff and said this is what I'm
doing I'm doing a project to try to
unmask the identities of your fallen
covert operatives can I get any help I
don't want to sound as naive as I may
sound in that it was really a way of
setting down a bookmark and saying this
is what I'm doing I'm not trying to end
run you I want you to know this is you
know what I'm up to and they they had me
over we talked they tried to dissuade me
from doing it and in the course of the
total of four years they provided many
courteous return phone calls and zero
cooperation did you ever ask them
off-the-record why they wouldn't
cooperate with you well they just
invoked the sources and methods argument
that I mentioned before that was it you
write up a 1998 ceremony that George
Tenet the current CIA I guess they call
him DCI the director of Central
Intelligence had inside the agent
see what were you there I was not who
was and what was it I was not allowed to
be there no one from the press has ever
witnessed the ceremony
it's an annual ceremony in which family
members of the deceased are brought in
from all over the United States they
don't know each other they only go once
in their lives know there some of them
go back repeatedly um usually the
ceremony has a focal point it may be
losses in-laws or it might be the the
mideast the one that you're referring to
which was the most recent one that I
could get into the book was was a
standard memorial service held before
the memorial wall and the book of honor
at the agency headquarters and I had the
agency for warns the families that they
are not to discuss what happens there
with anyone but they don't even trust
the families they will not say the names
of the deceased except for the name
stars even if the ceremony so you have
family members sitting there knowing
obviously that they lost a son or a
husband but even in that context the
director central intelligence will not
utter the person's name and in the
particular chapter the epilogue that you
mentioned I had pre-arranged with many
of the families to meet with the moments
after the ceremony so that I could
debrief them and superimpose each
account on the other weeding out what
was repetitious so that I could
reconstruct in great detail what
transpired at the ceremony that's how
that was constructed you'd talk about
one time when one of these families
groups were being honored and they got a
call from the president LBJ to come to
the White House
remember that one oh yes that was John
Merriman John Marilyn's
story is particularly sad he he was
killed in the Congo in 1964
his widow Val and son John are people
that I've gotten to know quite well in
the course of my reporting and they were
at the the director central
intelligences office to receive a medal
and immediately not long after they
arrived
a call was placed from the White House
inviting them to to come over and meet
the president and and Lady Bird and so
they did go over there and you know
there's no mention of it in the logs at
the White House I I went through the
Johnson library there's no reference as
you know was all hush-hush how did you
get this picture of his wife getting
some kind of a word he has probably the
the intelligence star she she provided
the photo to me but they allowed this to
be taken them yes but with the
understanding that that it would be
in-house that it would not go out and in
her case it's very strange because John
Merriman is a name star not a nameless
star but what's what's most peculiar
about this memorial is that even the
name stars are completely unknown to the
people who work at the CIA because
everything is compartmented the only
thing you know is what you have a need
to know so that in a sense it's not that
different being named or unnamed it's
it's different for the family because
being unnamed means you can't talk about
your loved one where is this picture up
top there with the two little kids and
his wife I believe that's taken in
Alaska and that that's John and his wife
Val he was a very courageous flyer and
and there's a sad irony to his story
well by the way what year is this
picture oh let me see I think 52 and
have you talked to any of these people
in the picture yes well his widow is
that is the the woman there's wife Val
and there she has an aside yes and right
and the young boy he's holding up that's
that's John Merriman Junior
actually not a junior because there's no
H in his in his name there wasn't the
father's but not the sons I've spent
many many hours with them they're
absolutely delightful people where do
they live by the way I John was right
outside of Washington and Thal lives in
Arizona and that picture was very new
husband the one that we have over here
no that's with her son that's your son
oh yeah that's her son John and how much
time did you spend with them and what
did they tell you about their father
well I think I
probably interviewed each of them I'm
not sure maybe it 15 times I mean it's
hard to say I mean probably four or five
really formal interviews but many many
many the subsequent follow-up phone
interviews what year was he killed 64
what was the circumstances he was flying
a plane in the Congo helping to suppress
a communist insurgency there and he took
ground fire and crashed and he was
presumed dead and the rest of the
squadron returned to a remote base there
and the next day some indigenous people
there drove up with a truck and a
crumpled-up body in the back and it was
the body of John Berman who was very
much alive although in agony and he was
taken to the base hospital which didn't
even have aspirin much less doctors or
nurses he had nothing to treat his pain
he had numerous broken bones lacerations
internal bleeding the straps from his
seatbelt had slashed into his skin and
he was allowed to stay there without
medical attention for well over I think
was over a week he was in agony passed
in and out of consciousness and and when
he was conscious all he said was take me
home take me home and then he was
allowed essentially to to to waste away
in a Congolese hospital for another
couple of weeks before he was any
attempt was made to bring him home and
he died and root over the the ocean and
the saddest part is that his widow was
told that he died in a hospital in
Puerto Rico that he had asked for ice
cream they had brought him ice cream and
he died quietly in his sleep without
pain he was never in Puerto Rico he
never asked for ice cream he died on a
transport plane after great agony what
was he supposed to have been dying in
Puerto Rico that part of the I think he
was I'm not sure what part of the cover
story how far sophisticated they got but
the local newspaper in Tennessee where
his home was reported as his death
certificate did that he was killed in a
car crash in Puerto Rico hitting an
abutment so how did you how do you
know that what you know about him in the
Congo is accurate about information come
from
I interviewed the Cuban pilots that flew
with him that he trained in the flew
with him
I interviewed the chief of station at
the time and the agency
I interviewed probably 40 or 50 people
that were familiar with what he was
doing in the Congo is his name on a star
his name he is named but I asked
probably 50 or 60 current covert
operatives if they knew who John
Barrowman was and none of them knew who
he was none of them knew anything about
him had never heard of him
why'd he try and Cuban pilots the Cubans
after the the Bay of Pigs remained a
resource for the CIA to conduct
counterinsurgency activities they hated
Castro there was nothing more they could
do to dislodge Castro after the fiasco
Bay of Pigs they had enough distance
from the US government being Cuban that
they gave the US government some
deniability many of them were trained
pilots from the Bay of Pigs so they
simply became a kind of surrogate Air
Force for the CIA what was John Merriman
doing in the Congo
he was there to supervise the Cuban
pilots he was actually technically not
supposed to fly but he couldn't resist
it he he was truly a flyboy he loved to
be in in aircraft where's this picture
of him with a bear it is a bear that was
in Alaska he shot the bear and it
bothered himself because it was such a
majestic creature that he swore off
hunting ever after who was Hugh Redmond
who ends up in three different chapters
yes and unfortunately in three different
chapters because it reflects the the sad
attenuation of his life he was in he was
supposed to be a businessman in Shanghai
prior to the the Communists taking
control of the government there in fact
he was a knock an NOC a-- anon under
non-official cover he was a CIA person
actually he went over even before there
was a CIA and then became a part of the
CIA when it when it came into being in
47
he was arrested trying to come home he
was he was helping nationalists within
China conduct sabotage supplying them
with information and probably weapons as
well
he was arrested incarcerated for
nineteen years much of it held
incommunicado
he was beaten at points he was starved
he suffered from malnutrition as he lost
his teeth prematurely just terrible
record of agony and he never admitted he
was a spy
the US government never admitted he was
a spy and if they had he probably would
have been released at that moment you
have a picture right next to the one I
showed of him as that his mother by the
way that's and it is right there yes and
then right next to it our three women
and a man with pictures what's that from
those are the mothers of Downey and
Fecteau and the brother of one of them
that they were on their way to China
that the Chinese government granted
permission for the mothers of Downey
facto and Redmon all three CIA spies
held in Chinese prisons to visit their
sons who had been imprisoned for many
years and and all the while the US
government denied that they were CIA
spies is here Edmunds name on a star no
it's nameless and and it dates back to
1970 when it was said that he slashed
his wrists with an American razor in the
Chinese prison we have no idea how he
really died because the Chinese waited
three months and then handed us an urn
of ashes again any reason why after 4050
years of this that they can't you know
from the what actual year did they throw
him in prison he was imprisoned in 51
and he died in 70 did what they do with
the body they cremated it and turned the
ashes over to the Red Cross who carried
it over the bridge the lower bridge into
Hong Kong and presented it to a American
embassy officials thing what happened
done those 19 years with his mother his
mother pleaded with the government to do
everything they could to get him out I
think it was four times she visited her
son it was a horrible kind of
stroboscopic experience watching your
son age prematurely he developed all
kinds of tics and ailments he was never
treated properly and and he became he
was very tough but he was not immune to
the kind of despair that one would
encounter seeing your whole youth passed
before your eyes and his mom
it just it just disabled her with with
pain and regret to see this happen to
her son but there was one from Yonkers
she was from Yonkers they had the whole
the townspeople involved in this
oh it was very sad that the Yonkers
community was completely behind Hugh
Redmon's mother and every effort to free
him they had fundraisers they had all
kinds of Appeals to government it was an
incredibly celebrated case not only in
Yonkers but in the Northeast and and to
some degree around the country at the
time and the sad thing was that it was
allowed to feed into the anti-communist
anti-chinese propaganda because the way
the US government allowed it to be
played is that here was an innocent US
businessman held for 19 years when in
fact he was a trained CIA operative
probably engaged in direct sabotage or
certainly assisting sabotage I'm not
sure what government wouldn't hold a
saboteur in prison but that conflicted
with the Cold War objectives so they did
not acknowledge that he was a spy what's
the average age of these people that
you're writing about
I would guess certainly they died
prematurely there were a few that might
have reached a mature age but I'd say
the average age is probably early 30s
and what happened to them in most cases
when they were killed how would you how
would the CIA bring the bodies back here
and what did the press say well the
press was always fed a lie the press was
always told that these were State
Department employees or workers for a ID
the agency for international development
or civilian employees the Defense
Department or employees of foreign
corporations so that the the press was
never told who they really were what
they were really doing the widows or
widowers were informed of the loss there
was a ritual in which the director
central intelligence would pen a letter
to the the widow or widower expressing
his deep regret and sorrow and that
would be presented to the widow or
widower along with a metal
and then both the metal in the letter
would be promptly withdrawn within a
matter of an hour - usually immediately
after the funeral the agency would
recollect them and put them in a locked
vault so there was no evidence that they
indeed worked for the agency what kind
of money is available to widows families
normally they would get the same kind of
compensation that any other government
employee would would get that is it's
not that they there's certainly no
windfall involved in losing your life
for the agency it's a it's a kind of
employee compensation and that's it
it's it's it's you know federal laws
that govern a Department of Labor and
all the other agencies and departments
it's not a special provision for for
agency people who was the wife that
refused the insurance that was John
Merriman's widow Val because it was it
was a double indemnity policy that they
had taken out years earlier as newlyweds
and she was given the double indemnity I
forget how much it was I think was an
extra $5,000 and she believed that
because he was in essentially in combat
that it was not warranted that it was
fraud and that her husband would not
want her to accept the money and so she
returned it and the agency actually met
with the president of the insurance
company to explain the situation and
still Val Merriman did not want the
money she she thought it was tainted now
you had something to do with that story
that broke at White Sulphur Springs West
Virginia I did I had something to do
with it
The Greenbrier which is a four-star
resort in West Virginia under which a
top-secret government relocation center
had been operating since about 1959 or
1960 until I exposed it in 1992 in The
Washington Post that was what is that 40
was 30 30 to 33 years that was one of
the most sensitive secrets in the US
government it was the place to which
Congress was to go in the event of
nuclear war and from there they were to
govern as a government neck
so why did you break it I broke the
story for a number of reasons and and
mind you there are a lot of Secrets I
know that I've not written and won't
write I just to mention one there's the
identity of someone who's not named in
the book that I know and I refer to
because it could compromise national
security so I don't write everything I
know but the Greenbriar story I wrote
because it was an anachronism it would
not have worked and the only reason it
survived all those decades is because of
secrecy what happened was the people who
ran it got a kind of literal bunker
mentality where the enemy was not
foreign powers but the American people
that is disclosure it's what they feared
most
and so administration after
administration Speaker of the House
after speaker the house you know was
basically they knew about it but they
had no opportunity to reassess it the
reason I broke a couple of things one a
recent Speaker of the House at the time
Tip O'Neill told me that he never would
have gone and nor would his colleagues
because there was no provision for their
loved ones their family they would have
been left to be incinerated at Ground
Zero so that was one reason I wrote it
is because it was impractical another is
because the nature of nuclear warfare
changed so dramatically in the
intervening years that the whole idea of
it was preposterous the the amount of
time you had for warning had been
reduced to minutes not hours you said it
was an anachronism was that your
decision that it was an anachronism or
was that somebody else's well it's a
good question the preliminary the
first-level decision was my decision
that is the decision to pursue the story
but the decision to publish in the
Washington Post was not my decision
I had input I was consulted but
ultimately that was the decision of the
publisher and the editors of the paper
because it was of a magnitude that
warranted that level of decision making
you know they asked me what do I think
and and what do we lose what are we risk
here but ultimately the decision was
there as and rightfully so and if they
had told me this is not appropriate to
break because will harm national
security I would have honored that I
would not have taken it elsewhere you
say that there is a name that you didn't
use in the book because you would
compromise
security in what way to reveal the
identity of this individual could put
some other individuals at risk and could
compromise ongoing operations I guess is
the generic way to describe it how do
you know that I don't know it I take it
as something a matter of faith but good
faith in that the agency at the highest
level made the argument to that effect
with some some degree of specifics is
the director of Central Intelligence
talked to you about this I did not talk
to me but talk to the editor of The
Washington Post at a time when I was
contemplating revealing her identity in
the post I was a woman and and it was
decided that this would not be
appropriate and I might point out that
it is the only name at the time I was
disclosing the identities of seven
nameless stars in 1997 in the Washington
Post Sunday magazine and I gave those
names to the CIA just part of
publication they came back and they
pleaded with me to delete the one name
they made no argument on behalf of the
other six all of whom were nameless
stars and to me I cannot help but wonder
if something is national security how do
you slice and dice and say well this is
more sensitive than this I showed that I
was approachable and and by deleting
that name and yet they made no such
argument for the on behalf of the other
six and in doing the book they had
gained enough respect from our reporting
skills to know that I had penetrated the
system and they never came to me asking
for other names to be deleted did you
submit the manuscript of your book to
the CIA on I would not do that
what I did do is I gave them a copy of
the book of five days or six days before
publication that's all but I would never
submit a manuscript to the CIA did they
complain about anything they they
complained about the project at the
beginning and then they resigned
themselves to the fact it was
to be done I think in the end they had
two emotions one they were aghast the
degree to which their own people had
cooperated with me and two they were
much relieved that I treated these lives
with the dignity and respect to which
they were deserving here's a picture of
a man named Maloney who is he
Arthur Maloney was a veteran of of
Normandy a West Point grad and a true
combat officer and he was wounded
shortly after a Normandy and because of
his wounds he could not pursue his
military career and by default he
entered the CIA and he is in the book
both of his own right and also because
his son became a CIA officer and his son
was on helicopter that in 1965 crashed
in laws and on that aircraft his son's
name was Mike Maloney and on that
aircraft was another Mike named Mike
dual by the way who's in this picture
with Mike Molly um that is his widow
Adrienne on the aircraft were two CIA
case officers Mike Maloney and Mike dual
and they had something in common they
were both that's Wally dual Mike's
father Mike duels father and then over
here pointing in the river is Mike dual
his son and what what the two Mike's on
the helicopter had in common was that
they were both the sons of senior CIA
people they both had very young Brides
they were newly married and let me get
this straight yes and both of their
wives were pregnant at the time that
they were killed they were killed in 65
and their identities hushed up this is a
picture here of Mike Molly with a small
child is that who's that do you remember
uh I believe that that is Mike that's
Michael Maloney his son and the other
son is in utero Craig and so that's the
so where were where were the two Mike's
the two Mike's were in law's part of
what was then called the secret war
which was increasingly becoming less
than a secret and they were flying a
helicopter and they crashed near Park
say into a very dense jungle and were
killed instantly and the US Press
reported the death of two aid officers
Agency for International Development and
for 35 years that stood no one linked
them to the CIA in 1997 in a post
article I disclosed that Mike Maloney
was CIA not a ID and what is sad about
that story is that his widow Adrienne
for years had asked the CIA to recognize
her late husband by name to put his name
in the book of honor at agency
headquarters for the benefit of her sons
her two sons as you talked to Adrienne
Oh many times
it were to salinity she lives in was
calm and in Connecticut and she was told
by then DCI the director Central
Intelligence John Deutsch write me a
note
you know don't doesn't have be anything
fancy just write me a note we'll see
what we can do about getting his name
recognized in the book of honor she
wrote him a note didn't hear anything
sent a letter registered mail didn't
hear anything called was told her
letters were lost and they basically
ignored her and wandered to go away the
day that my article came out they called
her and said they changed their mind and
they put his name in the book of honor
how often when you at night for instance
how many names in your book are not on
the wall how many in other words you
name people in here that are that
they're stars on the wall at the CIA but
names aren't there right roughly how
many new names are in this book oh that
are not young on the wall yeah oh I
well the stars are on the wall but their
names are not in the demo no names on
the wall I would say that there are
about about thirty five new names in
this book well they put the names in
there now they are re-examining it I
would like to be optimistic and say yes
but they have this incredible talent for
taking fiction over fact they seem to
believe that if they ignore it it will
go away I mean just just as a
example they won't allow this book to be
sold in the CIA bookstore it's it's it's
selling out fast and McClain at
bookstores private bookstores as CIA
personnel buy it but somehow by not
allowing it to be sold at CIA
headquarters it's as if the book doesn't
exist it's it's it's the idea of fiction
over fact in the back of the book though
having said all that you talk about
Aldrich Ames Douglas grote James
Nicholson and John dodge and who why did
you mention all them in the back
well I wouldn't lump them all together
other than that I used the scan room
rule I would get Deutsch out of there
because the other three were essentially
traitors to the United States I
mentioned them because I think they're
reflective of a very deep problem at the
CIA which is the obsession with secrecy
it's my belief that the obsession with
secrecy is more of a threat to national
security than lacks secrecy that because
everything has been classified secret
and top secret people within the agency
no longer take it seriously its
credibility is eroded and what happens
is that individual case officers make
their own decisions they say well it's
classified but it shouldn't be
classified at this level or it's
classified but it won't hurt if I share
this with someone so what happens is
someone like me comes along and I'm the
beneficiary of that obsession with
secrecy because many of those people who
help me should not have helped me under
the rules of the CIA but they took it
upon themselves to make the judgment
about what should and should not be
classified this is a direct result of
the obsession of secrecy john deutsch
took enormous ly sensitive materials and
put him on and put them on an unsecured
home computer and that is reflective of
a lack of respect for the security
system some of the spies that you
mentioned you know they part of their
defense at times was yes I gave the
enemy classified materials but it was
classified but shouldn't have been
classified it did no serious harm well
that opens the door to this kind of
individual decision-making which is
truly a threat to national security
other names Matt Gannon and his brother
dick Matt Gannon was a CIA case officer
who was one of the agency's finest
Arabists it was a wonderfully likeable
Southern California boy who who was was
from a very large Catholic family and
had the ability to pass in the Arab
world because of his language skills his
knowledge of the culture he was very
brave and in December of 88 he was in
Beirut otherwise he in this picture with
all the folks in it I know he's at the
bottom right there we showed him yes
he's in the bottom right and he is in
the in the other picture as well trying
to pick him out I think he is in the
front I think he's the lad in the front
with arms crossed and the top that's the
family that's the family it's a very
large family and and Matt Gannon Matt
Gannon and he he was in Beirut gathering
intelligence on hostage situations there
Americans were being held this was in 88
and and on some of the fundamentalist
terrorist groups in the region and he
did such a fine job that he got
permission to come back a day early to
be with his wife and two daughters this
was a couple days before Christmas in
1988 they had the misfortune of boarding
a flight called Pan Am 103 which was
blown up by terrorists over Lockerbie
Scotland his brother dick Gannon is a
security officer with the State
Department who had survived the blast in
83 in Beirut when that embassy was blown
up so the family has been touched by a
share of terrorists who's James spessard
James spessard known to his friends as
Jimmy was one of six CIA employees or
contract people killed in 89 in a
resupply effort in Africa they were
bringing materials and weapons
explosives to Jonas
of mb in angola and the plane that
spessard was on hit a treetop it was a
night landing they fly by night there to
avoid detection it cartwheeled into the
ground exploded and six CIA employees
and staffers were killed and in at least
two of the instances maybe three there
was nothing to bury there were empty
coffins this is him in the white suit
that's right and what's the occasion of
that picture
let me see that's with his father and I
believe that that was it yeah that was
his wedding in 81 and where did you get
the information on him from his widow
from his father from co-workers from
people that served with him in Angola
and and in the United States where's his
widow today she's in Maryland and this
picture is of their wedding back in 1981
it is did you have trouble finding
information on some of these people and
just have to give up um yes no uh yes I
had trouble finding information on these
people no I did not give up I mean I
their stories that are still out there
they didn't make it into the book I'm
sure that there are I would be
incredibly presumptuous and egotistical
to suggest otherwise but I didn't give
up on anything everything that I was in
pursuit of I did ultimately manage to
get but not very efficiently or
effectively for example I tracked one
false lead three and a half months I was
told there was a plane crash in El
Salvador that took the lives of six
people I spent three and a half months
an interview probably 200 people in
pursuit of that and it turns out that
was the Angola crash it was not in El
Salvador so that sort of thing happened
in the course of reporting this book how
much money does the CIA have intense
budget every year I don't know
you know there's it's it's never been
made public we know that in terms of
intelligence from a figure released I
believe was last year there's more than
25 billion in terms of intelligence
gathering all around but the NSA gets a
large portion of that the National
Security Agency which which does
intercepts communications intercepts and
such the CIA you know their budget this
is just a guess but you know under 10
billion ya know how many people work at
the CIA I can take a stab at it
somewhere between twelve and fourteen
thousand is that the number of dollars
and the number of people going up or
down in this time period in our history
well it's fluctuated under Reagan I
think it did quite well under Bush it
did quite well actually I think it's
relatively stable now they're rebuilding
they lost an enormous number of people
in recent years with the demise of the
Cold War the end of the Cold War it
might have been a victory but it almost
undid the agency because their reason
for being was removed in the eyes of
many and so a lot of the most
experienced people left
they said the job is done and they
walked away or they took retirement
there was a generational cycle you say
that you're from Canton Ohio originally
where did you go to college I went to
Brandeis in Waltham Massachusetts and
Trinity in Dublin Ireland what did you
get at Trinity
I studied classics I studied Latin and
Irish poetry are you married I am how
long you been married 18 years how many
children - David and Matthew nine and
ten and how long do you work for Time
magazine six years and the Washington
Post eight years anybody else that
you've worked for over the years besides
your freelance um I worked for the Akron
Beacon Journal for a year I worked for
the virginian-pilot
Norfolk and I worked for the York County
coast door in Kennebunk Maine as a
part-time sports writer at the very
beginning you say in the book this is
your first it is what was it like well
it's funny I have a great reverence for
books probably too much so and I knew
that my life was not going to be
complete unless I did a book and I was
really 44 or 45 before I started this
and about that time I was trying to
resign myself to the fact that this was
one thing I wouldn't accomplish in life
and and so this book was was a true gift
in many many ways because I I didn't
want to do a book that I didn't care
about absolutely I didn't want to just
do a book to get it on the Shelf I
wanted it to be something that mattered
to me and matter to others
and when this presented itself I knew it
just felt like that wall reached out to
me I know that sounds kind of overly
romantic but that's how it felt have you
personally stood before the wall many
many many times yes you dedicate the
book to the sons and daughters of the
CIA stars named and unnamed alike and in
memory of my father who told me the only
thing a man may hope to leave behind is
his good name when did he tell you that
throughout his life he died 26 years ago
at my age he was 50 and I'm 49 but he
told me throughout his life that there's
nothing you can take with you and the
only thing you can leave behind is your
good name and there was a kind of play
on words there because of these nameless
stars and I had a feeling that this was
something that my father would have
approved of and taken pride in so that's
why I dedicated it how did you get a
grant from the MacArthur Foundation the
research for this I had no one who would
support me or help me with this
initially I borrowed against my life
insurance policy for several months to
keep going and gotten something of a
financial hole and then I I sold a part
of the story to the Washington Post
Sunday magazine they were very generous
in supporting a part of the research
that preceded the publication but I went
through those funds as I continued
researching went to the MacArthur
Foundation and they alone among all the
foundations in the country would have
anything to do with me because it was a
kind of scary project involved the CIA
it was unclear how much progress I would
make or what would come of it and to
their credit they crawled out on a limb
with me and and supported me can you
tell us how much initially it was to be
fifty thousand and I turned back 15
because I later on got a very large
advance from Doubleday and I did not
want to take what I didn't need you tell
us to write here about one of the men in
this picture they ended up in
Connecticut at age 84 he goes as Richard
Bissell he goes all the way back to the
Bay of Pigs which one is he in that
photograph with Jack Kennedy let's see
he's the gentleman to Kennedy's
right yes with the glasses and the paper
in his hand and he's right down here
below right picture that's the
retirement who is he still alive
no he passed away and when did he pass a
couple of years ago did you meet him no
I spoke with his widow I spoke with
several of his children neighbors
friends people that worked with in his
personal assistant lots of people and I
read his book and and many of his
writings what's the story on Richard
vessel Richard Bissell was was was it I
hate to use this word because it's
overused but I think he was genuinely a
genius he was the father of the u-2 spy
plane and he was really responsible in
no small measure for the sr-71 blackbird
surveillance plane and he was
instrumental in the first satellite
imagery so so he was someone that
materially advanced our ability to keep
an eye on on those we wish to keep an
eye on he was also and probably even
prouder of his role in sponsoring covert
activities overseas he was a part of
that era in the in the late 50s when the
agency had a kind of carte blanche and
were active all around the world so he
was one of the architects of the
disastrous Bay of Pigs which is why he's
in the book because despite all his
triumphs he'll forever be linked to and
remembered at least in part for his role
in that debacle somewhere in here and I
forgot where I wrote it down you quote
Theodore Draper is having a comment
about the Bay of Pigs you remember what
it was what was this one about how could
I have been so dumb now is the one about
the perfect disasters on the oh yeah
perfect failure oh yes yeah right right
there there's another quote in there
about Kennedy saying how could I have
been so stupid but yeah it really was an
unmitigated disaster and it was foreseen
as such by Mani and that was the saddest
part is that what happened was that they
had a a a plan which may or may not have
been workable but at least it had the
indicia of possible success but it was
continually cut back and curtailed to
presidential deniability and prevent the
u.s. from being linked to it which was
absurd even as the operation was ongoing
the u.s. hand was all over it so what we
had done the u.s. that is is basically
we had condemned ourselves to failure
and-and-and for American pilots died in
the Bay of Pigs their identities were
known within weeks or months and their
identities appeared circulated in
newspapers and books around the country
for the ensuing three decades but the
agency refused to recognize their names
and they were nameless stars in the book
of honor quick recap the book of honor
stands for what the book of honor is the
volume at CIA headquarters in a
bulletproof glass case in which the
names of those killed for the CIA and
CIA are remembered and nameless stars
are etched in the books pay how many
stars are on the wall today 77 and the
time period you're talking about in your
book is from where in the win it spans
the entire history of the CIA from 1947
basically to the present if you had this
book to do over again what would you
change what would I change all I would
just work more efficiently I think
that's all and your base now at
Cleveland at Case Western Reserve
University right teaching what the
journalism and nonfiction writing our
guest Ted GUP this is the book the book
of honor
covert lives and classified deaths at
the CIA thank you very much thank you